[музика]
Всім привіт Я Роман Мені 24 роки і я
працюю трактористом і я дуже люблю свою
роботу
[музика]
з полем знайомий з дитинства Мій батько
теж був трактористом я пам'ятаю коли він
на жнива їхав і всі діти вибігали щоб
подивитися на машину її помахати рукою
йому а я стояв поряд і радів отак з
дитинства знають що робота почесна але
саме про таку професію я не мріяв просто
просто хотілося бути корисним у рідному
селі тому вступив до профучилища а потім
під час навчання пішов на практику до
агрокомпанія там і на роботу взяли
робота важка але й цінна та орати я
жнива теж я сучасна робота у полі вона
потребує до того ж за наших умов вона
потребує точності багато сил і енергії
Але мені це подобається я я просто це
люблю
До того ж зарплатня гідна жалітися я
точно не стану
робота в полі завжди була але сьогодні
вона життєво необхідна всьому світові
адже саме ми відповідаємо за те щоб у
людей був хліб на столі Мені подобається
що я потрібен
адже все працює завдяки нам
[музика]